[Music]
this week we've got moose dispute beer
treatment and browser alert [ __ ]
Meese me to me and I think that's how
you say moose plural it is have you ever
seen how big those Falls are massive I
want to try eating one verse you ever
seen a [ __ ] camel straight up bro
yeah they are the size of an f-150 dude
they're [ __ ] there was a truck that
brought them in it was that it was in
Florida and there was like a [ __ ]
camel riding thing yeah they were bigger
than the [ __ ] f-150 they were
standing next to yeah they're [ __ ]
huge nobody told me how big camels were
under eyelashes like a broom yeah it's
[ __ ] this dude rollin those
[ __ ] are big dude disgusting
was it a two hump camel or the one hump
camel was it the luxury edition 2.0 they
were huge but maybe we've got a smaller
one you must have got some small ass
ones because that camel was next to a
horse and that horse look like a little
[ __ ] yeah you big horse yeah the
[ __ ] you just got me like different
kinds of camels like like you probably
saw the diesel truck camel yeah that
thing was [ __ ] like it was like a
little baby on it and I think you have
camel pageants like Ford like horse
shows yeah they have them for camels
yeah these camels when I split the hair
down the middle and give it a little
mustache Oh that'd be cool sure what's
the name of that camel I'll appear I
want to see the air but about that we're
like there's nowhere that says akha dog
can't be a camel in there like you're
right alright
air but not PR the camps mess [ __ ] I
love it's good next dog you guys get
Pierre yeah hell yeah oh my god it's so
perfect yeah cuz I want to know
Coachella no culture America so what if
I pee on the floor right over here
alright so first story
Canada has always been known to have
[ __ ] Canadian beaches we're going on
spring break
hurry ass boots sexy [ __ ] I thought
they're nice people yeah so they all
save it and I meant so they've always
been known as well to have the world's
tallest sculpture of a moose they've
been known to cuz I didn't know that
where you been man cuz I guess it's been
common knowledge and I just wasn't it
farm where if someone but if someone
asked you where is the tallest moose
statue
you'd probably at least guess Canada
yeah be like Trinidad and done that's
true Canada would either be Canada or
North Pole yeah so it's been standing at
32 feet tall but then just recently
Norway unveiled a 33-foot come on
they're trying to battle yeah when will
the feud between Norway and Canada ends
he lives to the peaceful countries
always been like a friendly kind of like
oh yeah 32 I'll be 33 so because now
they've unveiled that the entire city of
Moose Jaw which is where the their
statue is okay well they should just
give it to them men if they named a
tighter city called [ __ ] Moose Jaw
Saskatchewan better than Moose knuckles
that was a close call man Oh moose
knuckle
that's a good call sac in a dick yeah in
the Bulge you know the camel toe
there's moose knuckle oh never heard of
that it's a male camel toe oh okay yeah
that's cool I never heard of that and
learn something new but uh yeah it's
been there since 1984 so these are the
two don't ya wins by [ __ ] Canada get
out which one's Canada well they made it
shiny too it's not just like slightly
taller it's just like this is chrome
addition over surfer's moose there's
looks way more realistic than a [ __ ]
metal one compared to the childish
[ __ ] claymation version [ __ ] if
you were like staring their phone was
staring down at you right yeah which one
would you want to be staring at you the
brown one right I'm not the claymation
one the one on the left looks like it's
got a bunch of hot soldiers hidden
inside I want to see the chrome one
during winter the first one
Norway like yes the mentally handicapped
version of that one because that one
looks like it's protecting the forest
that one looks like it's protecting
nothing like it's lost that's like the
protect stay away from this grass like
you got it the brown ones like the one
you see like in Santa Monica you throw
money on it like go buy yourself a
sandwich you so which one of those nice
are named Pierre none of them
that's a camel yeah look at them
shoulder blades on that metal gather
when she's yeah no it looks like a horse
that they just [ __ ] made it longer
smell like fatter smell I mean that's a
loose basically big-ass horse there
Janice look good I Jack like a horse
yeah I remember the ones who song
Colorado but it wasn't Jack door blows
maybe winters bulkiness oh maybe could
you [ __ ] gym owners dude yeah third
even on zou quadriceps on the rear man
those thoughts
okay giving them a [ __ ] physique
contest at your driving by small green
lights this is just like an
overachieving horse a horse is like a
tall a scowl and a cow is just a big old
fat dog and so on and so forth down to
like a little end up at the java mouse
deer that like to introduce we're small
there's no inch deer oh it's my favorite
animal look at that it's the world's
smallest mammal that's so cool too much
deer Java mouse deer I mean it's a mouse
but it looks like a deer get the [ __ ]
out of here I need to see that oh that's
great oh it's great it's got a big old
dumb but I want to bite one oh my god
that's crazy
I wonder what it tastes like it's not
even where it's like crawfish can you
have that as a pet I've looked into it
not that easy job really great so this
video booths job they started a GoFundMe
because they want a bigger one to Chrome
their [ __ ] out there move me Mac Mac
what's funny is that they just went just
like one inch yeah [ __ ] you yeah so
they're trying to raise $50,000 as of
right now they have more than $8,000
they gotta be like Dubai and be like
[ __ ] that this is the they gotta go way
big like you know how they have the
tallest and it's like by far you need a
moose Island yeah they need to go like
slow big guy like no one could compete
they just need to get the moose and then
[ __ ] put two dildos on top bunk on one
of the horns Beach and they went by the
eight inches oh yeah
what I was gonna say put the Moose on
rollerskates yes and then so you still
preserve the top part of the moose but
you give wheels at the bottom
well Norway uh so the sculpture artist
that created the chrome one for Norway
they said she said that they plan on
building another large moose but this
time it's gonna be double decide 65 feet
tall oh hi made of gold
you know I'm gonna steal that moves
Canada's getting smashed yeah what are
you guys gonna do nothing they're so
nice they're gonna say thank you all
right for our next story doctors saved a
man's life by pumping 15 cans of beer
into his body whoa oh my god I know why
why he's an alcoholic and he was
probably trying to smoke the withdrawals
and he was probably trying to just cut
cold turkey and then that's when he got
in trouble that's crazy how they don't
they can't get alcohol poisoning man so
what happened here is this 48 girls
Vietnamese man of course
dunking she fell unconscious I don't
know that means they pop they put IV
like a how much you want to mint that
[ __ ] was Heineken know they had the
[ __ ] hat with it you can how they can
with ice cubes in it I just pictured a
kid with the [ __ ] IV tap like into
there wake up it's like [ __ ] Coors
like you good no no Heineken
[ __ ] put an ice cube in the cup
- I somebody give me make sure you put
the thumb in my drink - a play thank you
in your dream yeah you have to when you
serve at the epidemic oh that's just
fire dude
know everything everything okay
sometimes they even give you the egg
rolls and one of them is like that yeah
so what happened years doctors found
that this man had a thousand times over
the recommended limit of methanol oh
[ __ ] so there's methanol in alcohol like
beer and wine yeah
but very like small amounts and then
producers they tried to limit like make
it the least amount because the body
can't break it down the methanol
methanol so and the so the liver
prioritizes ethanol to break down before
methanol so that's why they were pumping
cans of beer into his body because they
were it gave them enough time to clean
out his blood because they had to do
dialysis to clean up they'll
methanol in his blood and stuff how do
you so much methanol in there it's just
like he got my cheap liquors like you
just got that yeah probably cheap liquor
Wow damn Anthony's people they know how
to drink son yeah because what happens
is when the body is processing methanol
it turns into formaldehyde oh my god
yeah which is highly toxic and so that's
why this man is my calming fluid right
there yeah yeah don't drink people that
really somebody's a [ __ ] chemical
power plant really don't drink anymore
at all
stupid you probably drank like this week
it's fun I want you to know that just do
it in moderation I wish I could drink
and then me too actually you know it's
fun it's just the next day it's kind of
like that's where it gets a little wonky
I don't think I could metabolize ethanol
or methanol or whatever from all any NAS
I don't be like it I don't drink you
know I like I have but like I don't for
the past like several months I you know
it would always be like a like a beer on
an occasion here and there anyway but
I'd always just be like I feel bloating
and like makes me put on weight and I
just I'm not feeling it it's never been
my things yeah you feel sick when you
drink not during but like even even a
couple beers I would generally feel like
just really off the next day like not
hungover but just like I'm firing it
like 70% at best so that's the day of is
cool it's just the next day you don't
like do anyone yeah and also like I'm
come from like a long line of German
alcohol drinkers Germans love out they
sure do and it becomes a part of the
life so it's just like I gotta watch the
we went to this one bar called
hofbrauhaus it's like one of like and
then it's such a big drinkers place it's
like a country club dad in the back
there's lockers and people keep their
Stein's there no way so that's how like
frequent people come because they want
to use their own stein and they'll go
and they'll get a refill beer drinking
so interesting to me because it's it's i
don't know how people have seven or
eight beers it's it's a [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ] liquid and it's a [ __ ] ton of
calories so I don't know how you keep
ingesting it after you just ate a [ __ ]
ton of fried food so they peel ah yeah
but still like they're still so [ __ ]
bloated like I have like thanked
drinking
soda or whatever Oh cuz it tastes really
good I've got a really good beer but how
do you drink eight sodas I think that's
the sugar it makes it difficult but if
you drink yeah I guess it's like the
carbon a drink and a slice of bread yeah
hefty you get super [ __ ] full from it
so now I just drink hard liquor but then
it also makes food taste really bomb and
maybe because you're intoxicated like
your stomach and your brain are there's
a lot of thing that alcohol makes you
think that looks or tastes really good
and it's not a good thing right
that's true I [ __ ] the pillow when I
was drunk
[Laughter]
you that was the wrong thing and I I
just get sick so I just puke and I just
feel wrong I don't like it was it the
pillow you slept on oh yeah
isn't that better though than like I
found a different pillow somewhere in my
pillow and then he knocked out no
apparently what my mom said was I puked
outside they came inside washed off my
body and I as soon as I went to my
bedroom
I started [ __ ] the pillow I got up
and I pissed inside of the trashcan and
went back to sleep on the couch your mom
Saul she said she was cracking the [ __ ]
I wonder if they wouldn't let they will
stop talking about it for like ever
how old are you I was like 14 yeah dude
that is so funny you're like [ __ ]
that pillow and then the the couch
pullout size jealousy all that [ __ ] let
us see all that [ __ ] you monster I know
all right for our last story there is
this plug-in called Muse guard and Daily
Mail is very upset because there's
because of that plug-in this alert pops
up that says when you go to tell me
Malcolm
it says proceed with caution this web
site generally fails to maintain basic
standards of accuracy and accountability
they want them to remove that alert what
happened it's it's like a browser
plug-in that tells you
like just like you know how the virus
plugins would be like this isn't safe
this would suggest you know this new
source is not always reliable trying to
cut down on like what we talked about
yeah I see but I mean if I don't know
much about Daily Mail but like if it's
not a reputable beautiful site like
maybe fix your propaganda and you know
yeah what is I mean I've seen Daily Mail
I just didn't know like how popular they
were in the UK or whatever I feel like
they're probably like like a tabloid
pretty popular now like they're even on
just regular TV like they have their own
TV show here Wow
so they don't they don't like that pop
up no then do [ __ ] legit journalism
[ __ ] there you go yeah so then News
card developers are saying that they
tried to engage with them but they never
got back to them and so it just happened
like you know you never got back to us
so this is what's gonna happen to your
site well it's kind of good they have
this criteria you gotta do that for
every new source then yeah there's nine
journalistic criteria that they have and
MailOnline chose to not reply to them so
then they weren't able to see if they
meet that is bad yeah what's that they
didn't get to even see that they met the
criteria or not right because he never
met with them well yeah that's why they
have that pop-up because it's like hey
we weren't able to verify they're just a
nine journalistic criteria so just so
you know it may or not may not be real
then they should be then that makes
sense why they would be a little bit
more mad again I don't know anything
about the site so I don't know if it's
that reputable or not but like they
should be a little bit specific in those
warnings like even for like you were
saying regular news sources like if it
pops up it's like hey just so you know
this site leans a little bit more to the
left now be nice reading might be Tim's
door this side is known for being much
more right-leaning and that kind of
thing I don't know instead of just being
like we cuz even the old guard media
like CNN and all those guys they've been
around for a while but they've been
caught doing some stupid everybody has
and I think it's only because in order
for them to stay relevant and stay ahead
of the game they have to just report
[ __ ] while social media's reporting [ __ ]
so they don't have time to do research
so
so yeah I know there's just a lot of
they're not doing their their their
journalistic duties because they don't
have the time to they got to get the
news out now they can't keep up that's
not an excuse but at the same time it
does [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] up so they do
also have this alert pop-up for visitors
to right-wing site Infowars the
left-wing us political blog called daily
kos and the Russian government News
Agency called Sputnik Sputnik they have
the same yeah
so if you go on to one of their sites
you go hey guess what this is like this
is politically leaning it's the exact
exact same thing it says proceed with
caution this website generally fails to
maintain basic standards of accuracy and
accountability my question though is for
somebody that's going to like be aware
enough of our political and like
reporting situation to download that
kind of thing wouldn't they already do
that because they know yeah Infowars is
generally BS and like you know that kind
of stuff when they already know like I
don't think that's gonna be new info for
anybody like they're doing their own due
diligence already if you're concerned
enough to download an app for it
I say yeah oh it does okay that on what
like like on all browsers they're
reporting that's an atomic function to
edge Google Chrome Mozilla Firefox and
Apple Safari it's been a plug-in for a
while but then Microsoft updates edge
browser for Android and iOS devices and
then that's when it prompted a lot of
media outlets to report this story when
it started popping up more it's almost
like the majority of news sources are
they're politically motivated to report
things on the left you know people were
getting a lot of different perspectives
during the election because they
everyone thought Hillary was gonna win
because of how the news was pushing and
promoting it you know it didn't it
didn't accurately portray like what all
of America was feeling like I don't know
I think it's it's kind of [ __ ] up
because there's no I wish there was like
different new sources of all of that
represent all of our political parties
like not just right unless but they I
don't know like the Green Party channel
or the libertarian channel and you could
just flip through and watch and see what
these people think
yeah that'd be kind of cool and even
like beyond that you know I grew up in
Georgia and like Fox News was off and on
in the house and you know we'd switch
back and forth between ABC ABC and Fox
and all that stuff but I never remember
listening to Fox News and granted I was
a kid but I'd like to think I was pretty
aware of stuff I never listened to stuff
and was like that's really weird like I
feel like more in recent times it's
gotten much more extreme and yeah stuff
I'm like I wish there were like a more
conservative news source that weren't so
crazy crazy I don't know like it does
feel very propaganda if I turn it on
down and I'm just I'm saying like
left-side stuff does that too but I mean
like there's a lot of options for the
left there's not a lot of options for
the right it's just one channel but
that's because I think what what's the
cuckoo I think it's Rupert Murdoch or
there's a there's a there's a
conglomerate news group or like a media
group that owns a lot of those networks
and a lot of them um they're owned by
you know people that put it there
they're politically leaning left they
have kind of an agenda because a lot of
their friends and all that stuff you
know so they don't want to report the
other side and then Fox is owned by one
conservative dude and and so there's
really no diversity in the media space
interesting
[Music]